lalala lalala lalala lalala lalala pas
vraiment quel beau tableau ouais mais où
va aller regarder françois qui vient on
la voit là je salue nous venaient à
temps on va regarder les dessins de plus
avant la solide vrai les riffs tackels
que je te fais de la dépression des mois
attendez moi je suis expert en
décideront des sols la voilà celui de
valérie la suite valérie suis pas
d'accord c'est très beau mais celui ci
est celui qui celui là qui a fait saint
branchs conseiler et le magnifique c'est
la maison sophie c'est pas beau et
annick de écoutez moi je vais vous
montrer
allez on va tomber en montrer parce
qu'il est trop belle à regarder le
tableau qui a fait que c'est meilleur
et le dal a passé tant et brooke tableau
j'attends kazemi quoi tu sais désunir
chacun ses goûts 1 mais tout à l'heure
tu étais tellement désagréable que
j'hésite pas te dis ce que je trouve ce
dessin très laid voilà la raison
allez on laisse tout ça venait dé me
wade
qu'est ce que c'est c'est moi tu ne me
reconnais pas à masquer du style bonjour
monsieur 19 ans voire plus d'une heure
et demie ratant une seconde
on dirait que tu veux me fuir - oh non
pas du tout à leur approche
j'ai quelque chose à tous deux montés
qu'est ce que c'est ne fait pas le sou
de ne pas me françois non il est parti
au revoir
casimir attend une seconde qu est ce que
tu caches là où ça là devant on vend
rien rien d'autre moi non oui non oh
quelle horrible chose bon c'est une
peinture de toi non c'est pas moi non
les enfants peut-être maintenant qu'on
soit pendant julie alors non plus non ce
doit être alors un vrai artiste peintre
qu'il a oublié un artiste célèbre mais
oui quelle parade
quelle finesse de coloris quel point de
dessin
ah oui je comprends tout casimir tu
voulais me cacher que tu es en
possession d'un chefs-d'oeuvre de la
peinture moderne
à 16 heures
[Musique]